here's a crunchy topic the whole panel
can get its teeth into there's a new
cricket tournament it's called the
hundred and begins next summer stars
such as Owen Morgan Heather Knight Ben
Stokes and Jafra Archer have all caught
the selectors eye that's the good news
the bad news depending on your worries
about the link between advertising and
the national obesity crisis is that the
sponsor is KP snacks players will look
like they're wearing shiny crisp or nut
packets I don't like it
Ben Stokes would have to make a hundred
and five runs just to work off the
calories of one packet of cheese and
onion crisps or Nick Ferrari would have
to run somehow on five miles ago maybe
that's like the harsh on mister fast and
furious Ferrari but you see where I'm
going with this I mean should we really
promote cricket by turning players into
vending machines for high-fat salty
snacks I think you're probably right but
I don't know who who's gonna stop them
I think only governments can do these
sorts of things not you can't ask a
cricketing authority to say oh no I'm
gonna choose which sort of which sort of
sponsorship money I'm going to take
they're basically trying to maximize the
money so they can have a successful
tournament and they're very worried
about kids not actually taking up
cricket so that's why part of isn't
they're doing it but I don't think you
can ask them to be the arbiter
I think you've government have got to be
the arbiter well shirts I mean they do
do it like walking Chris packets but
Rachel's and it looks less like a
commercial thing that's driving kids to
not to pick up a cricket bat but to go
buy the FA though I think 500,000 kids
who who are playing football because
McDonald's sponsors it now yeah it's
it's a difficult decision you've got I
mean like I remember Gareth Southgate
talking about getting young kids
interested in football and you're you're
if you're supporting at the same time
the obesity of children is
kind of counterintuitive yeah I think
that's right but I think in the end
sports authorities won't do it you've
got if you want it down it's got to be
done by government and you guys there's
a woman called Babs crab and she's the
cauldron of children's food come here
she says and let me just call she said
she's the English cricket should be
using its power to support efforts to
half child abuse - by 2030 no they
shouldn't
it's not their job it's not their job to
teach kids to eat healthily it's the
parents job to teach their kids to you
tells me and I to push maybe the NHS no
let me finish my point the point is that
the whole point of their England the
world's quicker board the ECB I think is
this to maximize the funding of cricket
that's what it's there for that's its
job so maybe if you see itself in in the
foot and breaking its pact of let me go
on I decree and now I want to read this
ago this is a statement from at the
England and we're two quick boards it
says all goal for cricket is to connect
communities improve lives by inspiring
people to discover and share their
passion for quickest across their
portfolio of brands KP has almost
unprecedented resources board into the
lives of all Britain's diverse consumers
and is keen to work with us to help grow
again they are absolutely doing their
job the ECB and Debbie KP on board Carol
- just two quick points one we know that
there if you are trying to get a fit and
attack address the obesity crisis we
know that what's far more important than
taking it says is how many calories you
put in calories in is much more
determinant or whether you're fat than
calories that secondly advertising
really sells product when Walkers crisps
used a sportsman Gary Lineker
to sell crisps the sales of those crisps
went up by 105 it's yes but also you're
you're creating you're adding to the
problem the point is if this who is
going to be the Lillywhite advertised
that you want to take on the sponsorship
of this cricket tournament because are
there that many saintly people matter
that you couldn't say oh that's going to
be bad for the health it's going to be
look this is a cricket tournament that's
going to reach out to kids in urban
communities inner cities they wouldn't
have at all not at all
you'd be like jafra archer who's become
a great cricketing hero would be
supporting this I can't support the do
you think this
shirts are valid in in terms of
advertising right we're good tell you I
have far more worries I think we're
looking at the wrong no I'm not I can't
get worked up about it Roach and I'm
terribly sorry I can't and I worry more
about the fat kids a gambling that's
much more James I know there can be
sixteen ads for a gambling company in
one football magic ninety minutes an NHS
clinic for young people with gambling
clubs are sponsored by gambling
companies hey homie love warm is
sponsored by tobacco commented sports as
a business yes I'm not sticking out the
KP but this is what they have to say we
believe snacks can be enjoyed as part of
a balanced diet and healthy lifestyle
including regular exercise see we
recognize you have a responsibility to
provide people with healthier snacking
choices which is why since 2005 reduces
salt and hula-hoops by 42% and in our
core McCoy flavors by 25% additionally
29 products in our range are 100
calories or fewer per pack so they're
doing that sauce so you're talking about
weighing up the benefits of yes they're
advertising unhealthy food but at the
same time they're promoting decent
health and sport that's foreign activity
but I mean if you're wearing up those
two things standing in a field for a few
days in the Sun and eating unhealthy
snacks I'm thinking it's not really
balancing out in the right in the right
way I mean even Simon Stevin sort of the
chief of NHS England says that he's
worried that this might outweigh the
benefits of the product the whole point
of the tournement 7 is to encourage kids
to take up active sport and they may not
just come on it's a great space a look
pretty fit to me you may like cricket
authorities are worried that the cricket
has been on pay television for a long
time hasn't been on terrestrial
television and the numbers taking part
in cricket have gone way down and what
they're trying to do this is gonna be on
the BBC as well as sky and they
doing that because they want to
encourage kids to wake up and that's a
good thing this week we've had that what
you Dame Sally Davies now you called
Reggie has also attacked KP this deal
between KP snacks and the English
cricket border as counterproductive
could end up with people just sitting on
the sofa eating snacks rather doing
anything she's gone on to say and I want
to know what the panel thinks of this
that we should ban snacking on commuter
because she thinks that obesity is the
second major it is armed enhancer it is
the most preventable something about she
suggests you know we talk like eyeball I
think she's great
fantastic she's just about to retire me
replaced but you see look at the sugar
tax and the sugar tax has been effective
no it hasn't it has not reduced obesity
that wasn't I'm so you know so much that
it hasn't
what did you've done what they've done
is reduce reduce the amount of calories
going into heavy into all these drinks
but that's what sugar tax is done and
the answer it's the government if they
want to do it to expand the sugar taxing
to all sorts of other areas if they're
really worried about obesity and we
should be worried about obesity and the
problem that you guys have got is that
yeah because your complete free market
if you live in this difficulty that I
actually sometimes government
intervention is good sorry I worried
this sports festival which is a great
thing which could become an annual event
might not happen without KP but I just
want I just want to come back and quick
you know I know you just had a good
business thing I know everything the
fact is the statistics do not back up
the fact that the sugar tax has reduced
to obesity levels it hasn't doubled its
reduced the calories getting into those
drinking but not obesity levels right
well I do have some really appetizing
crystals for you as a treat that is
because you've all worked so hard and
you've burned off so many calories at
the end of this program we've got
special packets of pledge crisps we've
got
Andrew Ito's they're hot and spicy but
firm family favorite is Greggy salted
them one for the kids
Femi fry and then lastly the crisps are
gonna divide the nation
Malone monstermunch somos I can tell you
now parents can be embarrassing at the
best of times from dad dancing to
meddling mums it's bad enough when your
old man cracks out his signature move at
your wedding but even worse when he
decides to turn up at a protest you've
spent all week talking down so spare a
thought for Prime Minister Boris Johnson
who might have spotted a familiar face
at the extinction rebellion protests in
Trafalgar Square Wednesday blonde hair
big fringe lover of Latin this member of
the Johnson clan might look slightly
familiar to some of you pledges I'm
totally fine with that I think I would
wear that badge with pride I really
would I'm in fact I'm uncooperative
classy I mean why not why not I'm gonna
get a little badge made uncooperative
crusty no fine it was after dinner and
Jake is a good one first to keep it in
the family
yes dad so for embracing your status as
a non-cooperative crusty Stanley Johnson
you are a lean mean green machine of the
week Rachel would you be next the light
picture Tonto fires go I'm really proud
of what he's done over his entire career
in raising an environmental awareness
and I'm proud to be the daughter of the
Straight Talk of the week this week oh
he's fantastic that